здасть це виколоти нас митник минув його
обидва збори ти
маленькому казкарю малюнок та їх
чеченець чи рада прибрала друга лійна пара
фарбол його на дотик і годину євромайдану
зняв з постаменту перейменували улов
на те привезли до твору all the monster
них піду слабкі сторони та владний до
міс загалом у депутата вигадуємо та
посилається приліпити і вуса гарний
заробіток адреса олега шеїна кроти знову
знайшлося а настало чекотто депутати і
створа не державного музею тоталітарного
режиму куди за законом про
декомунізації можна з воза ти так і з
paddock адже так пам'ятник виставив вона
продаси за 300 кілограмів бронзою хоче
виручить і близько 400 тисяч гривень про
курси до креативних ідей депо такі
встав і не різанини
метою ніхто заливаю народжувала манометр
зняли зняли слова хвилі зняла це і
зняла і слава богу дай бог галас лікарі
прийшли фон ціла вона на увазі борошно диму в
українці зараз і в євромайдан адаманту
вали більше тисячі рівненських пам'яток та
наді їх просто ламав і
і ноги після падіння пам'ятники на вигляд
будинку куди знак червоною проти нас
оборони як у нас м'ясо я пам'ять таки вже
не що ви скажете у полетів культурний
dieci неодноразово за кликала влада
дикому не золото батьківський спад хреста
консультації з експертами миття ми
щоб декомунізація стала конструкти
зовнішню починає про декомунізацію вимагаю
починати з його нікому не заводитись і
спаду кого спитаке ясную за раз в
українці через його перервати абсолютно
зайнятий цьому євро і не їхати вдалося
прихід дзвони на вампір портвейні на все
всі лікарі в клас ти нос хапаю
інфраструктуру та ревіталізація потикатися
хто червоний in dem сам і так хоче труби
ти в коржах
і аксіони знаючи duty покупки у вождя з
бронзи тут треба аромату ватою майже всі
адже можна ось я до використання бульйону
на благо якщо наші особливо